imagine you're arts in Africa it's
nighttime you're sleeping in the back of
a open vehicle and it's so hot that you
have no clothes on and you're still
sweating all you can hear is Justin call
of a hyena
an Impala snorting close by and you're
half asleep but then your car just
begins to wobble you're not quite sure
what's going on tilt your head up and
you look down towards your feet and all
you can make out is your clothes bag
sort of on the box next to where your
feet are and it's just all of a sudden
that disappears so quite startled and
set up and grab a torch and you shine
out into the darkness and all you can
see is a young male line running off
into the bush carrying all your clothes
I I grew up in the bush and now as a
wildlife filmmaker I can continue to
spend most of my time out in the wild we
choose not to have a camp we like to
move with the animals and it keeps us
close to where they are we sleep where
they are it keeps us in touch with what
is going on and the filming vehicles
that we've got a modified for filming we
like to be able to see and smell and
hear everything around us we want to be
as unencumbered as possible so we we cut
off the cab we take the doors off and
you know fold the windscreen down and
the vehicles are just completely open
this little bag incident that happened
happened last year to us while I was in
savuti filming Savage Kingdom and it was
the young male lion from the marsh pride
that thought it would be quite funny to
sneak in there grab my clothes back and
run off with it it was quite a busy
night you know as you do you jump into
the driver seat and you start chasing
after the guy and of course you
completely naked because now all your
clothes are gone and we chased them
around for but
20 minutes before we managed to manage
to get all my clothes back I've actually
I've still got my bag I still take it to
the bush I still use it quite like this
bag
despite the sort of holes that he had he
left in it I come from a long line of
Botswana bush people my
great-grandfather was one of the first
up there he he was knocking around all
over the place he was a hunter he got
mauled by a lion at one point and
involved in quite a few other
misadventures I believe my grandfather
who is that man up there he followed my
my great-grandfather into Botswana and
was given the yoke of anger as a hunting
concession to shift crocodiles
specifically he was quite an intrepid
guy a bit of an adventurer so a lot of
time on his own and he used to take
these little tin boats and carve his way
into the Delta and basically shoot as
many Crocs as he could he could find he
would go up there with groups of guys
that would do all the skinning and
prepare the skins and salt them and get
them ready to be taken back to South
Africa to be exported off to Europe but
he lived a wild life and and really
explored a vast part of the Delta in the
mid 50s and early 60s he was responsible
for killing probably about 20,000 Crocs
during his time as a hunter before he
himself was killed by a black mamba on
one of his hunting trips he he got
bitten and and died and now of course
it's completely safe to swim in the
Okavango it's just which is not
altogether true but what it did is gave
way to another generation of bush people
my parents then moved up into the
Okavango they took over what with old
hunting camps and kind of broke the mold
a little bit and
that of hunting they decided to build
the first photographic tourism camp in
the Delta and that was in 1967 a few
years later my sister and I were born
and we were born literally into the bush
and into the wild the story goes that my
mother had me in Mau on a small village
quite close to well the base of the
Okavango and she figured that it would
be safer to take me out into the bush
then to leave me in the village so that
four days old she picked me up and did
this long boat journey up to the camp
where we were living and as she arrived
at the lodge at the campsite she was
getting out of the boat and onto the
land and she didn't want to pass me on
to somebody else just as her baby you
know protected and climbing out she
slipped and dropped me straight into the
river
so I was baptized into the Delta at a
very young age the life the next four or
five years we grew up on my sister and I
grew up on this island out in the middle
of the Delta my folks used to go into
town maybe once a month at most to go
and get a few suppliers get a bit of
fuel and they we lived a sort of rural
life we we lived in small read huts
you know we lived on we slept on the
floor under mosquito nets and you know
bath time was in the river because there
are no Crocs at the time and in a tin
bath next to the fire it was very sort
of rudimentary and and a great existence
my folks used to go out and catch fish
and try and subsist to a large degree my
mother had a little vegetable garden
that she used to the constant war with
the wildlife you know fight off the
porcupines were trying to eat her
tomatoes or whatever she was trying to
grow but essentially we sort of lived
off the land my dad got a pot license
that he used to have that he could go
and shoot a few animals that he could
then feed his staff or have food in the
camp with
but that really wasn't my dad's star he
he didn't really like the hunting side
of things and instead he used to take
this little yellow short felt best Land
Rover that we had and we've got trekked
lines and find the lines and then we'd
sit on them and follow them for four
hours and eventually they would kill
something a buffalo or parlor or kudu or
something and then he would use a little
Land Rover and push all the lines off
the kill hop out and Captain Lego for a
shoulder or piece of meats and then he
would take that home and that's really
how we got most of our most of our food
and our meat you can imagine as a little
toddler how exciting that was that was a
grand adventure looking back at how I
grew up really sort of you know looks a
little bit like Mowgli in the sort of
jungle book story it was it was a wild
life we we grew up surrounded by
predators we had lions hyenas leopards
always around us and a lot of other
animals that can kill you elephants
hippos Crocs and even snakes like the
ones that killed my grandfather
growing up wild like that sort of gives
you a sense of vulnerability
you're not top dog you living in a world
full of predators and it makes you very
aware and very vigilant and you're
always very focused on what is going on
around you and very perceptive towards
the bush and I think that's where my
love for the wildlife and my sort of
passion and my understanding of the
predator world really started began
where it all stemmed from very soon
after I left school I joined two great
people which most of you probably know
dereck and Beverly to bear they
explorers and residents for National
Geographic and they lived in the bush
and they lived where I wanted to be and
I started an apprenticeship with them up
until this point the bush and the wild
animals was really just my life it was
normal I was very familiar with it
I sort of just moved through life you
know not really appreciating that
bringing that head and dereck and
Beverly kind of shifted that direction
and made me
they sort of contextualized the value of
my upbringing and the sort of
understanding that I'd naturally
accumulated by being out there they
allowed me to look at match in a very
different way in a much more
philosophical way and really delve
deeper into appreciating these animals
in the natural world I was working with
them for about 10 12 years towards the
end of that time I met my wife who was
at the time having her own sort of
midlife crisis she was giving up her
life as a lawyer in the big city and
decided to move out into the middle of
the bush with me so the two of us we had
a new direction and a new purpose and we
were determined that we were going to
live and stay out in the bush and as it
happens not long after we did that we
had some children and we went well we
weren't gonna let that stop us so we
moved everybody out into the bush and
and we decided to live out there we both
really believe that it's a gift to grow
up wild
grow up in the bush and we wanted to we
had an opportunity to give that to our
children so we're hell-bent and staying
out there we could slowly teach them
about tracking about the signs of the
wild we could teach them about how the
bigger animals the scary animals are
often the more gentle animals and we
wanted them to grow up strong and have
this intrinsic sense of nature and
animals sort of embed into them at a
very very young age let them develop
their own intrinsic understanding and
and compassion towards the wildlife and
luckily those tin baths didn't evolve
much in 25 years old very very useful
it's amazing how we often we so often
follow the path of our parents this is a
pic this picture was taken in 1979
that's my my sister and myself getting a
few lessons in life right out in the
middle of the Okavango and this picture
was taken just over a year ago and he
took the picture we were out there with
our family living the wild life being
out there in the bush just in a totally
different location
[Music]